♪ ♪
>> Sean: THE FAR LEFT UNHINGED
RADICAL SOCIAL AGENDA WAS ON
DISPLAY AT AGAIN TODAY, EXTREME
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST LED BY
JERRY NADLER UNVEILED A CORRUPT
SCHEME TO PACK THE COURT AND
EXPAND THE NUMBER OF JUSTICES
FROM NINE TO 13 AND WHAT IS
NOTHING MORE THAN A BRAZEN POWER
GRAB TO DESTROY SEPARATION OF
POWERS AND ADD POWER IN
PERPETUITY AND CORRUPT ONE OF
THE MOST SACRED INSTITUTIONS AND
GET THIS, FOR THE IRONY, THE
DEMOCRATS COURT PACKING DEBACLE
IS BEING UNDERMINED BY THEIR OWN
ACTIONS BECAUSE REMEMBER, THEY
ARE "WE NEED NINE" CAMPAIGN IN
SUPPORT OF MERRICK GARLAND IN
2016, DON'T FORGET BEFORE
JOE BIDEN WAS COMPLETELY
CONTROLLED BY THIS RADICAL LEFT
SOCIALIST GROUP, HE THOUGHT
COURT PACKING WAS A BONEHEADED
IDEA.
HE WAS RIGHT THEN AND WRONG NOW,
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SO WE ARE HERE AS A COALITION
OF BEGINNING THE EFFORTS TO
ENSURE THAT WE RESTORE JUSTICE
TO THE SUPREME COURT.
>> IT WAS A BONEHEADED IDEA.
TO SPEAK OF THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT IS BROKEN.
IT IS OUT OF BALANCE.
AND IT NEEDS TO BE FIXED.
>> IT WAS A BONEHEADED IDEA.
SOME PEOPLE SAY WE ARE PACKING
THE COURT.
WE ARE NOT PACKING IT, WE ARE
UNPACKING IT.
SENATOR McCONNELL AND THE
REPUBLICANS PACK THE COURT OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
IT WAS A BONEHEADED IDEA.
>> IT'S TIME TO GO BACK TO THE
TRADITION AND HAVE AT LEAST 13
JUSTICES.
>> IT WAS A BONEHEADED IDEA.
>> WHEN THOSE SEATS ARE FILLED,
WE WILL FINALLY HAVE A COURT
COMMITTED TO GOVERNMENT BY THE
PEOPLE.
>> IT WAS A BONEHEADED IDEA.
IT WAS A TERRIBLE, TERRIBLE
MISTAKE TO MAKE, AND TO PUT IN
QUESTION THAT FOR AN ENTIRE
DECADE THE INDEPENDENCE OF THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT BODY INCLUDING
THE CONGRESS, IN MY VIEW, THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT BODY IN THIS
COUNTRY, THE SUPREME COURT OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
>> Sean: YOU SEE WHAT I MEAN?
JOE BIDEN TODAY IS NOTHING LIKE
THAT GUY.
NOW PELOSI CLAIMS SHE WILL NOT
BRING IT TO THE FLOOR, BUT YOU
CAN'T REALLY BELIEVE HER AND
THEN ADDED, OH, YEAH, SHE WANTS
TO HEAR FROM BIDEN'S COMMISSION
WHICH SHE WILL RECOMMEND COURT
PACKING A NEXT UP ON THE DOCKET
FOR DEMOCRATS, D.C. STATEHOOD,
PUERTO RICO'S STATEHOOD,